[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: We're here today with
a very dear and old friend
of mine, Fran Hauser, whom I
met when I was working in LCS.
And she was our client
while she was at "People."
So this was over a decade ago.
We met at one
fateful, fun dinner.
So those dinners that we
do for our clients really
do pay off in spades with
friendships to last the years.
So Fran I have been
in touch while she
has been on her journey
of writing and publishing
this book.
And it's really a
wonderful and candid read
on some of the experiences
that she's had personally.
Experiences about women around
her, women that she's mentored.
And as we can see
by the turnout,
it's a very relevant
topic for most of us.
So Fran is a startup investor,
a longtime media executive
and former president of digital
at Time Inc., the author
of "The Myth of the Nice
Girl: Achieving a Career You
Love Without Becoming
a Person You Hate."
She has held senior positions
at some of the world's largest
digital media businesses,
including Time Inc.'s "People,"
"InStyle," and "Entertainment,"
as well as AOL and Moviefone--
sorry, "Entertainment Weekly"
as well as AOL and Moviefone.
She's now an angel investor--
so switching into the tech
industry--
who largely invests
in female founders,
and named one of Refinery29's
six most powerful women in New
York City's tech scene and one
of Business Insider's 30 women
in venture capital
to watch in 2018.
She's been featured on
CNBC, Forbes, Vogue.com, Ad
Age, and more.
Please welcome Fran Hauser.
[APPLAUSE]
FRAN HAUSER: Thank you.
Thank you.
SPEAKER: Thank you.
FRAN HAUSER: What
an amazing turnout.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
FRAN HAUSER: This is incredible.
SPEAKER: It's really amazing.
FRAN HAUSER: So good.
SPEAKER: And I think the--
like I said, I think the topic
really just impacts so many
of us.
Just to quickly
kick off, I think
when I read the book
it felt like a letter
to my younger self, but still
so many things that I struggle
with day to day.
And I think it's
one of those books
that if you have
it on hand there
will be chapters that will
be more relevant to you
throughout certain
parts of your career
and give really practical
tips and really key takeaways.
Just to keep those things
in the back of your mind
as you're going
through the situations.
So thank you.
I can barely look
at my book anymore
because, like, all
highlighted, and dog
eared, and notes on the side.
Fran went to sign my book.
And she was like, where?
[LAUGHTER]
FRAN HAUSER: Oh my god.
I love it.
SPEAKER: So maybe I'll
take a clean copy.
FRAN HAUSER: Which, by
the way, let me just
add one thing about that.
That was really my goal
with the book is I really
wanted it to be actionable.
[INAUDIBLE] I worked with
at Time Inc. for years.
And I think you
can vouch for this.
I am an operator at heart.
I execute.
And it was really
important to me
that there are tips and
techniques and strategies
and things that you can actually
do, that you can incorporate
into your everyday work life.
So that's the best
compliment that I can get
is that you have all of that--
SPEAKER: All the notes, yeah.
And just the little
catch phrases
or the little descriptors
that just stick in your mind.
Even if you don't realize
it when you're reading it,
you'll catch yourself in
that moment doing the things.
So we'll talk about a
few of those today that
really stuck out for me.
But first, obviously,
who here has
felt like they've
either gotten feedback
or they've recounted a situation
in the back of their mind
where they felt
like being too nice
has kept them out of
an opportunity at work?
And we're all in this
room for a reason, right?
It's really something
where I think
our culture here
at Google really
wants everyone to
bring your full self
and to have the psychological
safety to share your opinions.
And so with that, you
think it's kindness.
But the truth is in
business, sometimes, you
feel like that could
be a liability.
So in your book
you talk about how
the word nice is emotionally
loaded, particularly for women.
I would love to hear how
you define being nice.
FRAN HAUSER: So specifically
when it comes to work,
when I think about
a woman or a man,
actually, who's in a
professional environment,
and they're nice, I think about
somebody who is empathetic,
who's collaborative,
and who's confident
that there are enough
opportunities to go around.
And I think that last
part is really important,
because that's really more of
an abundance mentality, where
it's not like, if you win,
it means that I have to lose.
There's a real generosity
that comes with that.
And the premise of
the book is actually
really simple, in
that if you're nice,
if you do all those
things, you're empathetic,
you're collaborative,
you're generous,
what that does is
it engenders trust.
And when you have
trust, that allows
you to build a relationship.
And at the end of the day,
being successful in business
is all about relationships.
It all comes back
to relationships.
And the other big
message in the book
is that you don't have to choose
between being nice and being
tough.
You can be both.
And there's that duality
that I think really
runs throughout the whole book.
So when I'm talking about
communication it's-- you can be
kind and direct.
When you're negotiating, you
can be empathetic and strategic.
So these things aren't
mutually exclusive.
SPEAKER: It's a very
important point.
FRAN HAUSER: Are you OK?
It's the almonds that we ate.
We were so hungry.
SPEAKER: We were eating
nuts before this.
Everything is fine.
Well, it's interesting when
you talk about the duality.
Because I did a program
in Oxford last year
where we kind of walked
around an imaginary forest.
And you were holding
an imaginary stick
in this imaginary forest.
And that imaginary stick
was your greatest strength.
And so you walked
around the forest.
You were talking with other
people in the program.
You had your stick with you.
So you're really
thinking about what
this greatest strength was.
And then they asked you
to think about a time
when that stick had become
your greatest weakness.
And how do you set that down?
So it's a really
interesting exercise.
But in the book Fran
talked about empathy
being your Achilles heel.
And I would love to
hear more about that.
FRAN HAUSER: Well, I
over-index on empathy.
And while empathy is
an incredible, I think,
trait, where it has
hurt me in the past
is when I care so much about
what other people are feeling
and thinking that it
makes it difficult
for me to make a decision.
Because when you
care so much, you
want to make everybody happy.
And you're getting buy-in.
And you're checking
in with everyone.
And that slows down the
decision making process.
And especially working in
technology or working in media,
you need to move quickly.
Time to market is everything.
Whether it's-- you're
working on a product,
and you're trying to figure
out which features to leave
in and which features
get scoped out.
It's really important to
keep the momentum going
and to move quickly.
So that's where it's
actually hurt me.
And I've had to make sure
that I pull back on that.
And that I really be aware of
that and be cognizant of it.
SPEAKER: Amen on that.
Because it is-- and I think
the nuance and the line
that you're drawing here is
collaboration to a degree.
At some point you've just got
to make a decision instead
of waiting for a decision
to be made for you.
But it's really
challenging, I think,
when you're so empathetic.
And you want to make sure that
everyone is feeling included,
and everyone is
along for the ride.
At some point,
particularly as you
grow into leadership
positions in your career,
people are looking to you
to make those decisions.
And people are looking to you
to be that decisive voice.
So it's been a very relevant
lesson for me recently.
FRAN HAUSER: Right?
And I think you definitely
want to show people
that you're listening to them,
and that you respect them,
and that you're
getting their input,
considering their input.
But then at the
end of the day, you
have to stand in
your own two shoes.
And you have to make
that tough call.
And when you inform the team
that you've made the decision,
I think it's great to
say, look, I really
respect what every single
one of you had to say.
And I took it into
consideration.
But at the same time, we
really need to move forward.
And I had to make a decision.
Some of you are not going
to be happy with it.
But we have to move forward.
SPEAKER: And I think
what I've found--
FRAN HAUSER: So there is a
way-- there's a way to do it.
SPEAKER: There's a
way, because actually--
FRAN HAUSER: It took me
a while to figure it out.
SPEAKER: --it provides relief.
Even if they disagree
with the decision
or feel like it's not going
in a direction they love,
there's a relief that a
decision has been made.
Anyway, I literally ran
out of highlighter ink
in this chapter.
Because this was, like I said,
just very relevant for me
right now.
And that's kind of
what I'm talking about.
There are stages of your career
were different parts of this
will be relevant.
And you'll remember
them to go back to.
So one of my favorite
Maya Angelou quotes
is the one where--
and I'm going to
slaughter this--
but when a woman stands up for
herself, unbeknownst to her
she stands up for all women.
You had a great anecdote
during your time
at Moviefone when you were
the only woman in the room.
And I think we can all
relate to certain meetings
where we've been the
only women in the room.
Can you share that
anecdote with the room?
FRAN HAUSER: Yeah.
So this was probably 15
years ago at this point.
So I was the only
woman in the room.
And I was a lot younger.
And we flew out.
I was the general manager
of Moviefone at the time.
And my team and I flew
out to LA to meet with one
of the big movie studios.
And we were ushered into
this conference room.
And we were waiting for the CEO
of the movie studio to come in.
His team was there.
We were just kind
of waiting for him.
And he walks in.
And he says hello to everybody.
And then he turned to me and
asked me to get him coffee.
Because he just assumed
that I was the assistant.
And I just shook his hand.
And I said, oh, we haven't met.
I'm Fran Hauser.
I'm the general
manager of Moviefone.
And he was a personality.
I mean, he really
was larger than life.
And he's like, oh my
god, I'm so sorry.
He just kind of used
humor to deflect it.
And then he called
out to his assistant
and asked her to get him coffee.
But I think it really
was an important moment.
Because, look, if I was just
out of college and someone
asked me to get coffee,
I'd get the coffee.
Would I be happy about it?
No.
But I would still do it.
Because you want to
be helpful, and you
want to show that you
have a great attitude
and you have great energy
and all that good stuff.
But at that point in my career
I was running Moviefone.
So I'm not going to go get
coffee for-- like, it's just--
and I think the way that I
said it, too, it was very--
it wasn't emotional.
It was just very matter of fact.
Like, oh, we haven't met.
And it was fine.
And I think I set a really
good example for everyone
on my team, too.
SPEAKER: Yes.
So when I read this
part of the book,
what stood out to me
what you described
in writing was really--
we all have those moments when
you walk away from a situation.
You're like, oh, I
should have said that.
I had the best comeback
or the best way
to handle that like
10 minutes later.
And so you described
a little bit of that--
just like taking a
beat in that moment.
So when there's
times where you feel
like you're being
undermined or assumptions
are being made about you--
is taking that beat about how
you present yourself versus
how people are perceiving you.
And I think that really
came across to me
as something that was probably
wise beyond your years
at that stage to
have that moment.
But also setting that
example for the rest
of the people in the room.
Like, wow, that guy just
made a fool out of himself.
And at least he recognized it.
And she called him out.
But I'm probably not going
to make that mistake now.
So that's kind of the
paying it forward aspect.
So actually speaking about
speaking up in meetings,
I think one thing that I
notice here at Google--
and for those of you that
know me it's not a surprise.
I'm pretty outspoken, maybe
to a fault. Too candid.
But I do speak up in
a lot of meetings.
And I'm always fine to
ask a question and say,
I'm not sure if you
covered this already.
We're all multitasking
all the time.
I'm not sure if you covered this
already, or maybe I missed it,
or there's-- and asking
questions I think a lot
of other people in the room
have but are worried to ask.
So I know that this is a
common thing with women
in terms of speaking up.
And you have a great story
early on in your career--
I think it was at
Ernst & Young--
where you kept saying,
that's interesting.
Can you share a little bit
about the learnings there?
FRAN HAUSER: Yeah, I
mean, I was so young.
I was probably 23.
And Coca-Cola Enterprises
was our client.
And we were in that office,
in the Coca-Cola offices
for months at a time, working
until 2 o'clock in the morning.
And there was this imposing
older man who was a VP at Coke.
And I was just so
intimidated by him.
And every time he
was in the room all
that I could muster to say
was, that's interesting.
No matter what he said.
I was always like,
that's interesting.
Literally for probably a month.
And finally, a mentor of
mine, Lou [INAUDIBLE],,
called me out after one of
the meetings and just said,
you have to stop this.
Do you realize
what you're doing?
You literally just keep
saying, that's interesting.
It's so not interesting
for you to be saying,
that's interesting.
Just say anything else.
And I needed somebody--
I don't know if
you guys have ever
had a moment where you
just needed somebody
to call you out on something.
And when he did that, I really
made a commitment to myself.
OK, the next meeting I'm
going to say something,
even if it's short, other
than, that's interesting.
And I did.
And it was really hard.
And I was really nervous.
But I did it.
And it just made me
more comfortable.
I felt like every time I
was in a meeting with him,
I would say more and more.
And I would start sharing my
opinions and point of view.
And I ended up developing
such a great relationship
with this guy.
And he would come by my cube and
ask for my opinion on things.
And eventually, he
ended up hiring me.
I left Ernst & Young to go to
work at Coca-Cola Enterprises.
So that was a moment.
But I do see--
honestly, it's
2018, and I'm still
seeing in meetings that there
are a lot of women who--
they have so much to
say, but they're not
speaking up in meetings.
They're still quiet.
And I see it at universities.
I was at--
I was speaking six
months ago at a college
here in New York City,
where it was probably
150 people in the
room, mostly women.
And when it came time for Q&A,
all the men raise their hands.
And one woman raised her hand.
They came up to me afterwards.
They lined up one on
one to talk to me.
And I asked the dean
of the business school,
is this common?
And he said, every single time.
It doesn't matter
who's speaking.
Doesn't matter if it's
a man, if it's a woman.
It's always the guys
that raise their hands.
And it just-- it's
shocking to me
that even that generation
of college students--
we're still seeing this.
And by the way, there are
a lot of women that have
no problem at all, like you.
Which is incredible.
So what I say to
women like you is,
be aware of other women
that may be struggling.
And is there a way that
you can be helpful to them.
I know I've been in
meetings where I will say,
Sarah, you and I
were just talking
about this the other day.
You had such-- you had a really
great point of view on this.
Can you share it with the group?
And if you are somebody who
struggles with it, preparing,
I think, is really helpful.
If you're going into a meeting,
and you have the agenda,
make a commitment that you're
going to pick one thing.
And you're going to talk.
You're going to say something,
I think is really super helpful.
I share soundbites
and stock phrases
that you can use if you're
having a hard time inserting
yourself into a conversation.
Just knowing-- whether
it's building on that,
or I love that
perspective, and--
whatever that stock
phrase is for you.
Sometimes the hardest
part is getting started.
SPEAKER: Yeah, opening
your mouth and speaking up.
FRAN HAUSER: It's just
opening your mouth.
So having that stock phrase.
And then the other
thing I always say--
go back to what you
said about pausing--
is your voice needs air
to work, which means
you really have to breathe.
You really have to
stop and breathe.
Whether you're in a meeting,
whether you're in a one-on-one,
or whether you're
public speaking.
Making sure that you're
taking the time to breathe
is a big part of it, too.
SPEAKER: So one thing that
Fran is saying that I just want
to make sure is coming across--
throughout the book,
throughout each chapter--
so whichever chapter is
speaking to you at that project
or whatever you're doing,
is these five quick tips.
So what she's
saying-- like, the way
to interject into
a conversation,
give yourself that
moment to get the floor
and get the attention
before you share the content
of what you're saying.
Those types of tips
are really helpful.
And they're quick
things to keep in mind.
And I think the other thing that
should give anyone confidence
that is worried
about speaking up
is ask yourself if you've
ever been in a meeting
where somebody
has said something
that you were just about to
say and didn't raise your hand.
FRAN HAUSER: Right.
SPEAKER: You're like--
FRAN HAUSER: All the time.
SPEAKER: Damn, that was just
what I was going to say.
So your ideas are valid.
Your contributions are needed.
There's no reason that
somebody else should
have to validate that for you.
But give yourself
that confidence.
Use these tips to get the floor.
And then if you're
in a meeting where
you notice you're
trying to speak up,
and you don't have the space
to do that, find an ally.
Find somebody that can help you
to speak up in that next space.
FRAN HAUSER: And take up space.
I share a story in the book
where I was at a board meeting.
I was at a nonprofit
board meeting.
And this guy who I have
so much respect for,
he has a very loud voice.
He's very boisterous.
And he had the floor.
And I literally just
felt like I couldn't
get a word in edgewise.
And I just decided that I was
going to stand in that moment.
And I just walked
behind the chair
and just draped my
arms over the chair.
And it forced everybody
to look at me.
And it gave me the floor.
So I think the other thing
is, you guys may have heard
there's that stat that's--
when you're communicating,
that 7% of the effectiveness
is verbal and 93% is nonverbal.
Really think about that.
7% is the words that
you're using, the content.
93% is everything else.
It's your eye contact.
It's, are you smiling?
Are you taking up space?
Or are you closed up?
It's all of that.
So that's another thing to keep
in mind, too, the nonverbal.
SPEAKER: And when we think
about-- here at Google,
we've just gone through
our annual review cycle.
Just to switch gears here,
because you give a lovely shout
out-- and I don't know if
anybody in the room worked
on this--
to a Gmail plug-in
of Just Not Sorry.
So it's basically a plug-in
that will scan your emails
to find out if there's
times that you're
apologizing excessively
that you shouldn't be.
FRAN HAUSER: It's amazing.
SPEAKER: And I can't tell you
how many times I want to share
with people--
I had a woman email me from
the West Coast two weeks ago.
And I had emailed her
something at 10:00 AM.
And she wrote back to me and
said, sorry for the delay.
It's 7:00 AM her time.
I'm like, there
is no delay here.
You should be brushing
your teeth right now
instead of answering my email.
So those little things.
Can you share-- you
had some specific tips
about how you trained
yourself to stop saying sorry.
FRAN HAUSER: Well,
so a friend of mine
actually called me out on
this at work years ago.
And she said, you
apologize all the time.
And I didn't realize
that I was doing it.
And I didn't believe her.
So I actually went
into my inbox.
And I typed the word sorry
into the search field.
And literally hundreds
of emails returned.
And I started reading them.
And what I found was
exactly what you just said.
Literally, it took me four
hours to respond to someone.
And my response was
so sorry it took me
so long to get back to you.
It had been four hours.
And when you apologize
for such trivial things,
it puts you in a weak position.
There's no reason to apologize.
If you hurt somebody, of
course you should apologize.
If you do something that
really hurts someone.
But for something like that--
SPEAKER: If you ignore the email
for five days, fair enough.
FRAN HAUSER: Right.
I mean, but so
that's what I found.
So that's when I downloaded
the Gmail plug-in.
And it's brilliant, because
it basically scans your email.
And if you're using
the word sorry,
it just flags it for you.
I don't have to do
it anymore, because I
feel like now I'm pretty good.
SPEAKER: You've trained, yeah.
FRAN HAUSER: I've
trained myself.
But in the beginning,
it was really helpful.
And just rereading your emails,
I think really important.
I also found that if I replaced
I'm sorry with thank you,
that that typically works.
So it's more like, thank
you for the opportunity,
as opposed to, I'm so
sorry that I can't do it.
SPEAKER: Oh, got it.
So when people are
asking you things--
FRAN HAUSER: It's
just reframing it.
It's like being thankful
as opposed to leading with,
I'm sorry.
So I think that's really helped.
Having an accountability buddy.
Having somebody like my friend
who called me out on this.
I basically just asked her,
if you see me doing it,
just let me know.
So that's always helpful.
But so much research
has been done
on this, that women do
apologize a lot more than men.
Probably has to have
something to do with when
we were younger, I'm thinking.
But it is something
that we just have
to be really, really aware of.
SPEAKER: So we're going to
open it up to some questions.
If anybody has any
questions, please
feel free to walk up to the mic.
In the meantime, I will continue
to ask you another question
while folks are coming up.
It can't be just the
men, just so you know.
[LAUGHTER]
So I loved-- and this
is actually, again,
pretty pertinent to now, given
we're going through performance
review cycles.
But you talk about the anecdotes
around difficult conversations
and how you respond
assertively yet nicely.
Can you share some
of your strategies
to deliver tough messages?
FRAN HAUSER: Yeah, so one of
the pieces of research that we
did when we were
writing the book
was around the amygdala in
your brain and how it works.
And the fact that
it basically-- it's
looking for threats, physical
threats, psychological threats.
And what happens is
when you're feeling
threatened you go into either
fight, flight, or freeze, which
is very unproductive.
So that was really important
to me when I read that.
Because what that
made me realize
is when you're giving a
performance review, if you
start the review
with, look, we have
some stuff we need
to talk about,
that automatically is a
threat to the other person.
And you're going to have a
very unproductive conversation.
Versus starting it out with, I'm
your biggest fan and champion.
And I want to see you succeed.
I'm here with you.
And I have some things that
I want to share with you.
It's all about how you start
the conversation, I think,
is so important.
The other thing I would say--
and I wrote a blog post for
Forbes about this like 2
and 1/2 years ago-- is the
power of questioning, asking
questions.
And having the
person sort of come
to the conclusion on their own
in terms of what they really
need to work on.
And here is a very
specific example.
If you ask, what do you
think could have been done
differently, as
opposed to, what do
you think you could
have done differently,
it makes it so much
more objective.
It's not like a personal attack.
But when something goes wrong, a
product doesn't launch on time,
it goes over budget,
whatever it is,
I think framing it that
way-- what do you think
could have been
done differently?
Again, it puts the
person in a safe place.
So I think that's
always helpful, too.
And sharing larger context.
If you're giving somebody
advice about what
they need to work
on, in the context
of the company's mission or
goals, how does that fit in?
Because I do think
that's really important.
Aligning it and
tying it back to what
the larger mission of your
department or the company is
is also really helpful.
SPEAKER: Just takes that
personal attack feeling out
of it.
FRAN HAUSER: But really
making the person
feel like, I really
want you to succeed.
I'm here for you,
goes such a long way.
But then being direct.
SPEAKER: I'm like, I'll take
any feedback you have right now.
[LAUGHTER]
How am I doing in this Q and A?
FRAN HAUSER: You're
doing amazing.
You really are.
But at the same time
also, when you do
have to give that feedback,
being clear and specific
about what the person
needs to work on.
Because I have had
managers who are
a little bit more kind of
touchy feely, warm and fuzzy,
who were trying to
give me feedback.
But I'm not really
understanding--
SPEAKER: What
they're saying, yes.
FRAN HAUSER: What
do I need to do?
Be really constructive.
So it's sort of--
again, it's that dance.
It's that balance
of being really kind
and caring but being
specific and direct.
SPEAKER: Yeah, and if you feel
like you're not getting that,
ask for it.
FRAN HAUSER: Yeah, definitely.
Definitely.
SPEAKER: Let's take a
question from the audience.
Thanks for stepping up.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
Thank you for being here.
[LAUGHTER]
So I'm actually an
executive assistant here.
And something we deal
with all the time
is something that you mentioned.
People having the
connotation that when they're
assumed they're an admin,
it's a negative thing, which
is really frustrating for us.
And there's a lot
of admins in here.
I see you all.
And I'm sure you agree with
me, especially since it's
a very gendered role.
It's mostly women,
especially at Google.
And we hear all the time, they
thought I was the assistant.
And that's insulting to
us, as you can imagine.
And then a question kind of
based on that is, in my role,
especially--
I'll only speak for myself--
I feel like I'm often having
to be on the defensive.
Because since I'm
not an executive
like Bethany or my VP, people
try and take advantage of me.
And when I do push back,
the feedback I always get
is to be nicer.
But it's hard.
And so I'm just
curious your thoughts.
I mean, you weren't always
an executive, obviously.
Neither were you, Bethany.
And so how do women,
especially in roles
that are deemed unworthy,
as I dare say, be nice
but still push back?
Because it's frustrating
how it's like--
have a voice.
And then we're
like, but be nice.
You're supposed to be cheery.
Blah, blah, blah.
FRAN HAUSER: Well,
I have to say I--
SPEAKER: Thank you.
FRAN HAUSER: Thank you,
that's such a great question.
I always give advice to
women, especially if they're
coming out of college when
they're a little confused
about what they want to do.
They feel like they want
to work in business,
but they don't know exactly
what function or department.
I always say being an
assistant is amazing.
It's such an
incredible way to get
to know all the different
aspects of a company.
I mean, I think about when I was
at Time Inc. Sonam, you know.
With my assistants, they usually
worked with me for a year.
And it was my goal for
them that they got exposure
and that they would figure
out what they wanted to do.
So for me, I think
it's an incredible--
I think it's an incredible
opportunity, truthfully.
Because I think about
how I started out.
I started out in finance.
And I felt like I was so--
it was so narrow.
I couldn't move.
If I wanted to move
into marketing,
like when I was at Coca-Cola--
that's not going to happen.
I was in finance.
I couldn't move.
I feel like when
you're an assistant,
you have so much opportunity.
You could go wherever
you want to go.
So I think it's
an amazing thing.
I do hear you in terms of
the tension between pushing
back and being nice.
And I think that when you
are an assistant, especially
for your boss, for your
manager, you are there in a way
to make their lives easier.
So that is sort of-- that
kind of comes with the job.
But at the same time, I feel
like you should be helpful,
but you should never
be subservient.
If you feel like
you're being asked
to do something that
truly is subservient,
I think you do have
to bring it up.
I think you do have to
have that conversation.
I talk about in the book--
there was a young woman.
She was a graphic designer.
And she was really--
she felt like she was
being asked to do things
that she shouldn't be doing.
And I sat down with her.
We went through the
whole list of everything
that she was annoyed about.
And there were
certain things where
I felt like, you know what?
You kind of do have to do that.
She was making copies.
This was 15 years ago.
She was making copies
for the design team.
I'm like, you are the most
junior person on the team.
I had to do that when I was the
most junior person on the team.
But then she was being asked
to get coffee and snacks
for the whole team
every single afternoon.
That's not appropriate.
To me, that's not--
that falls into the
subservient category.
And I think there's a way--
I encouraged her to have the
conversation with her boss
which was, this is really
distracting for me.
I'm trying to get my work done.
And then I have
to stop because I
have to get everybody's order.
Could we create a sign-up
sheet and different people
can volunteer to do
it on different days?
What I like about that
is she's actually--
she recommended a
solution to it as
opposed to just going and
saying, this is bothering me.
It's like, it's
bothering me because it's
making me really unproductive.
And here's what I think
we should do about it.
But I do think you have to
bring things up like that.
My first year out of college
I probably got coffee
every single day for people.
And I didn't know.
I didn't mind it.
Because I felt like I was--
at that point, I was so new.
I was just learning.
And I just wanted to build
relationships with people.
And I did feel like
anything that I
could do to be hopeful
would be a good thing,
especially at that moment
in my career and my life.
And it goes back to
what you were saying.
You go through these
transitions in your career.
And you just kind of have
to know what's appropriate
and what's not appropriate.
Where do I push back?
Where do I kind of just do it?
SPEAKER: And I think there's
some helpful tips that--
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
thank you so much.
FRAN HAUSER: Thank you.
SPEAKER: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thanks so
much for being here.
So you talked about getting
the floor in a meeting.
You talked about how
you stood behind a chair
and people had the attention.
But I find at Google
the hard thing
is keeping the floor, especially
in an engineering space.
People are very task-oriented.
They're very decision forward.
And it can be hard.
I find women in
particular get cut off
a lot if they're kind of taking
their time like you suggested.
Breathing and thinking
through what they're saying.
They're just going
to get cut off,
because they're not getting
their point fast enough.
And someone else will
just make it for them.
And I find myself
doing this as well.
So how do you keep the floor
in an engineering meeting?
FRAN HAUSER: Oh, gosh.
[LAUGHTER]
That's a great question.
I think that-- so I
can tell you when--
in my career when
I've gotten cut off.
And there have been
many, many, many moments.
I will usually say, excuse
me, I'm not finished.
And I do.
I mean, again, you could
say-- you don't have
to come across like a jerk.
But you just say, excuse
me, I'm not finished.
And keep talking.
And sometimes that works.
I feel like if
you have something
really important to say
then you should say it.
And you shouldn't be afraid to
cut that person off and just
say, excuse me, I'm
not done, and continue.
I also wonder going
into these meetings
if you have a
sense of what it is
that you want to communicate.
If there is a way to even
practice ahead of time
and get a little bit more sound
bitey, if that makes sense,
if you know that that's the
culture and that's the dynamic,
that things are
moving really fast.
If there is an
opportunity for you
to prepare what you want to
say and to do it in a way
where you get your point
across really quickly,
that's another thought.
It's just practice.
Practice and prepare.
SPEAKER: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Huge fan of your VC portfolio.
I was just at the [INAUDIBLE]
this past weekend actually.
FRAN HAUSER: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So you talk
about being nice.
And I share the same values in
terms of empathy, especially
engendering that within female
peers, peer groups and whatnot.
Before coming to Google,
I worked in finance
for a number of years as well
as tech, which are quite male
dominated industries.
And not everyone
valued being nice,
rather expediency
and effectiveness.
And nice was kind of
an ancillary term.
And so I was wondering what
your experiences were when
not everyone valued being nice.
And it wasn't
quite so important.
And how you sort of combated
that being someone who
has a bit of a bleeding
heart and is more empathetic.
FRAN HAUSER: Yeah,
I think-- so for me,
it's really been always
about over delivering.
And whatever our goals were,
whatever our metrics were,
whether it was a revenue
number that we needed to hit
or monthly unique visitors,
I think the culture
that I always try to
establish with my team is
that we're going to deliver.
But we're going to do it in a
way that we feel good about.
So I never really--
it's not that I was
leading with the nice.
I was leading with,
we're going to deliver.
We're going to have some really
great results for the company.
But we are going to feel
great about the way we do it.
It's not just about winning.
It's about how you win.
And I think that when you
do both of those things
that you establish your
reputation for yourself
as somebody who can lead a
team to deliver great results,
but can also do
it in a way where
she's building relationships.
So I think it's a nuance.
But I do think it's
really important.
Because at the end
of the day, you
do have to deliver
for the company.
Right?
Like, that's--
AUDIENCE: If I may, so when your
teams would come into contact
with, say, other
senior managers who
didn't have the same
exact approach or finesse,
would you broach that topic in
terms of what kind of culture
we're breeding here
in this organization?
Or is that something that--
you're like, I'm doing
this within my team.
FRAN HAUSER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And I'm
sort of preaching
these values to the folks
that I'm working with.
So I'm going to let it
go with these other folks
that I'm not managing.
FRAN HAUSER: Well,
it's so funny.
I was just with a
woman who I used
to work with at Time Inc. who
I hadn't seen in five years.
I had lunch with her yesterday.
And she brought
up a story of when
we got this incredible-- when
we were at People magazine.
We were being compared a
lot to Sports Illustrated.
Because they were really the
first brand at Time Inc. to go
digital in a big way.
So we were constantly
being compared to SI.
SPEAKER: That's when we
were working together.
FRAN HAUSER: That's when we
were working together, right.
And they had their way
of doing-- that team
had their way of doing things.
And we had our way
of doing things.
And there was a big
meeting that we were going
to be having with the CEO.
Because there was
some pressure for us
to be doing things the way
that they were doing it.
And Karen, who I had
lunch with yesterday,
she recalled how much time,
and effort, and energy we
put into preparing
for that meeting.
But we went into it not from
a place of defensiveness,
but from a place of--
we feel really great
about our approach.
And there was no emotion.
But we were just--
it was our way.
And we ended up
convincing the CEO
that it was a good approach.
And I'm like, that
was so interesting.
Because I'd totally
forgot about that.
But it was one of many examples
where departments, teams
can have different approaches.
But for us, I always
instilled that.
I always instilled
that in my team.
That was the culture.
Sonam knows, because she
was part of the team.
It was just really
important to me.
And I tried as much as
possible with my peers
to have that kind
of culture permeate
into other parts of the company.
And I would say Time Inc. was
a pretty great culture overall.
Five minutes.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
SPEAKER: One other thing
that I will say, too,
that is shared in this book and
also a different book that I
read.
But if you're struggling
with things, too, sometimes
just approaching somebody that
is that friction point for you
and just saying, hey, I'm
really struggling with this.
And then helps you
launch into that.
It doesn't get them
on the defensive.
It's about kind of
providing that feedback.
FRAN HAUSER: Harvard
Business Review
did this great piece of research
around warmth and confidence,
which is--
you guys should look it up
if you're not aware of it.
Because basically
what it concluded
is that you are going to
evaluate someone first
based on warmth, and
second based on confidence.
And that actually goes
exactly to what you're saying
and to what you're saying.
So is this person-- can
I trust this person?
It's first, can I trust them?
And then, can I respect them?
But the first part is
the warmth and the trust.
And it's the way
that you project.
AUDIENCE: Project that
into meetings and stuff.
FRAN HAUSER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you guys.
AUDIENCE: So I'm working
on warmth and confidence.
SPEAKER: OK.
This will be the last question.
OK.
AUDIENCE: What can men do?
So I just want to lead with
a little bit of a concern
that I have.
I think men sometimes want to
help or often want to help.
And they're confused
about what to do.
And one example I've seen of
something that's not productive
is mutual public shaming,
where, at least man to man,
there is a certain amount of
unjustified public shaming.
And then that can, I think--
I've thought, like, OK, if I
was a woman, how would I feel?
And I think sometimes it could
feel like fake chivalry almost,
where--
not the thing, like, hey,
let this person finish.
But cases where they're--
it basically can amount to
sort of muted public shaming
between men.
It doesn't feel
productive to me.
So what can men do?
FRAN HAUSER: Yeah.
I think one thing
that I really believe
in is I would love
for men to have
an appreciation for
different leadership styles
and just really
understanding that women may
bring different traits to work.
Because that's one
of the things I'm
encouraging is bring
your whole self to work.
Don't check qualities
like kindness and empathy
at the door when you go to work.
And I've just had way too
many women in my life--
especially younger women--
say to me that
they work for men.
And that their male manager has
said to them, you're too nice.
You need to be tougher.
So there's nothing
constructive in that.
It's like, if you want to give
constructive feedback, great.
If you want to say, you're
spending too much time
getting buy-in, and you need
to get to decisions quicker,
I can do something with that.
But saying, you're too nice,
is not really constructive.
So I think just
having an appreciation
that there are different
types of leadership styles
that can work.
I think just being
really open to that,
is something that I'm asking men
to do as a result of this book.
SPEAKER: And I think
one thing that you just
said is exactly what
you should be doing.
If I was a woman, how
would this make me feel?
And that awareness
and your willingness
to come to a place
like this, and listen
to what's being told, and
ask a question like that--
you're aware.
And so the more
you're in meetings,
and you see these types of
activities or the things
that you've heard
your peers tell
you is really frustrating
to them, the more you're
able to identify your own
behaviors that may be seen
as this odd chivalry, or one
upmanship, or whatever it is
and kind of catch
yourselves of--
guys, is this productive?
Or is this just the way we've
been talking to each other?
And could this be a really
toxic environment for somebody
to come in and try
to contribute ideas,
because they feel like
they're going to be berated?
Maybe that's comfortable
for us one-on-one,
but in a group environment that
could be a lot of toxicity.
So having that conversation
with your peers
or when you see that--
is there a more constructive
way we could be having
this conversation right now?
And being aware.
But I think you're already
sounds like 80% of the way
there in that you're
internalizing some of this as,
how would this feel to me if
I were in different shoes?
I think that's really
the crux of inclusion.
So thank you.
So one last question
before we let Fran go.
Or really a comment.
Fran is a phenomenal networker.
And I know that
that is something
that for-- when I say
the word, I'm like, ugh,
I hate networking.
And we were just having
this conversation.
It's really just talking to
people, which I actually love.
So I feel like it's
one of those things
that your network becomes
so valuable to you.
And she's got some
great tips in the book.
So please do read it.
It's the final
chapter in the book.
But can you share some quick
takeaways on your views?
FRAN HAUSER: Well,
I think it's just
really being intentional about
it, making it a priority,
making sure that you set
time on your calendar,
whether it's once
or twice a week
to meet with somebody either
in a different department
or outside of Google.
I know that if I hadn't built
the network that I built,
I wouldn't have been able to
make this transition from media
to investing.
And I also feel like not being
parasitic, but being helpful
to the other person
when you're networking.
This young woman sent me a
note totally cold on LinkedIn
that I loved.
She said I'd love to get
30 minutes of your time
over coffee.
And I see that there are two
companies in your portfolio
that I think I can give you some
social media strategies for.
And to me, that was amazing.
OK, she's going to be
helpful to me, too.
Right?
It's not that she's just
asking for me to pick my brain.
SPEAKER: You
highlight that, yeah.
FRAN HAUSER: But
it's, how can you
be helpful to the other person?
SPEAKER: And it's
that quid pro quo.
And it's not that you're sitting
there talking to somebody
like, what can I get from you?
And what do I have to
give you to get it?
That's not what
this is all about.
But if we're not out
there to help one another,
we're all in trouble.
So with that, thank you
so much, Fran, for coming.
FRAN HAUSER: Thank you.
It was amazing, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]